[Music]
Ariana Grande is showing off that new
bling the singer took the stage at the
Songwriters Hall of Fame induction and
awards dinner in New York City on
Thursday night
it's her first performance since news
broke of her engagement to Pete Davidson
[Music]
and not even her signature high ponytail
and killer vocals could distract from
that massive rock later the pop princess
shared this bit of her fiancee to
Instagram and tweeted quote I can't
believe my life right now to be honest
if I'm dreaming please knock me the back
out it's been a whirlwind romance for
the lovebirds Grande was first spotted
wearing the sparkler on June 2nd after
less than a month of dating the Saturday
Night Live star
[Music]
and a source recently told et that the
24 year old has been dreaming about her
wedding day since she was a teenager
quote during her teen years she was
always very dreamy about a wedding and
she used to call friends and talk about
one day having that one special person
[Music]